This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In the classic children's film, Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory, a group of children win a private tour of a whimsical candy-making plant. There are massive gummy bears hanging from the branches of trees and larger than life mushrooms stuffed with whipped cream. The centerpiece is a decadent river of chocolate. A chocolate river. That's the most fantastic thing I've ever seen.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在经典儿童电影《威利·旺卡和巧克力工厂》中，一群孩子赢得了参观一家奇幻糖果制造厂的私人机会。树枝上挂着巨大的软糖熊，还有比人还大的奶油蘑菇。最引人注目的是一条颓废的巧克力河。一条巧克力河。这是我见过最美妙的东西。
10,000 gallons an hour. The children's eyes grow wide, but their appetites are even bigger. So many temptations are within easy reach. The kids become greedy and self-indulgent. Hey, she's got two! I want another one! Stop squawking me! Everybody has had one and one is enough for anybody. Now come along.
每小时一万加仑。孩子们瞪大了眼睛，但他们的胃口更大。触手可及的诱惑太多了。孩子们变得贪婪和放纵。嘿，她有两个！我也要一个！别对我大喊大叫！每个人都有一个，一个对任何人来说都够了。现在跟我来。
Yelling to temptation comes at a cost. One of the children falls down a trash shoot. One turns into a blueberry, another has carried away in the chocolate river. He can't swim. There's no better time to learn. This is cult going up the pipe. Call a plumber!
屈服于诱惑是有代价的。其中一个孩子掉进了垃圾槽。一个变成了蓝莓，另一个被巧克力河冲走了。他不会游泳。现在是学习的最佳时机。这是正在顺着管道上去的那个。叫个水管工来！
Stook in the pine trees, they won't cook. From Hansel and Gretel to the story of Euliceus tying himself to the mast of a ship, countless fables and stories have told us about the importance of self-control and the dangers of giving into temptation. These ideas have entered the world of science too. Psychologists have explored how temptations shape our minds and how self-control can mold our lives. This week on Hidden Brain, we explore a crucial and often overlooked ingredient of self-discipline.
困在松树里，它们煮不熟。从《汉赛尔与格莱特》到尤利西斯把自己绑在船桅上的故事，无数寓言和故事都告诉我们自控的重要性以及屈服于诱惑的危险。这些思想也进入了科学领域。心理学家探索了诱惑如何塑造我们的思想，以及自控如何塑造我们的生活。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨自律中一个至关重要且常被忽视的要素。
We'll also consider when it makes sense to exercise self-discipline and when it might be better to set it aside. In the early 1970s, a Stanford psychologist named Walter Michelle conducted a series of very simple experiments that would become famous around the world. The subjects in the experiments were children from a nursery school in Palo Alto. Walter Michelle wanted to know, how can children develop the ability to exercise self-discipline? He called the experiment the marshmallow test. This is how the typical Marshmallow test works. This is psychologist Celeste Kid, who works at the University of California Berkeley, 50 miles up the road from Walter Michelle's old lab. You bring a child into a room, the child is between the ages of three and five years old,
我们还将考虑何时行使自律是有意义的，以及何时最好将其搁置。20世纪70年代初，斯坦福大学心理学家沃尔特·米歇尔进行了一系列非常简单的实验，这些实验后来闻名于世。实验对象是帕洛阿尔托一家幼儿园的孩子。沃尔特·米歇尔想知道，孩子们如何才能培养出自律的能力？他把这个实验称为棉花糖测试。这就是典型的棉花糖测试的工作方式。这是心理学家塞莱斯特·基德，她在加州大学伯克利分校工作，距离沃尔特·米歇尔的旧实验室50英里。你把一个孩子带进房间，孩子年龄在三到五岁之间，
and you offer them a choice. They can have one marshmallow right now, or if they can wait until the researcher leaves the room and then comes back, they're told if they have not touched or tasted the marshmallow, then they're going to be given two marshmallows instead. The researcher leaves the room, they leave the child alone with the one marshmallow on the table,
然后你给他们一个选择。他们现在可以吃一个棉花糖，或者如果他们能等到研究人员离开房间再回来，他们被告知如果他们没有触碰或品尝那个棉花糖，那么他们将得到两个棉花糖作为奖励。研究人员离开房间，把孩子独自留在桌子上的一个棉花糖旁边，
the child is instructed to stay in the room, they leave the child alone with the one marshmallow on the table. The child is instructed to stay in the chair. Then the researcher is waiting to see how long before the child eats the marshmallow. And the thinking here is that there is a treat right in front of the child, presumably the treat is delicious, and the child has to make a choice between eating the delicious treat right now, or waiting to eat the delicious treat, and then potentially getting a larger treat in 15 minutes. That is correct. And when you do this, there are a lot of spontaneous strategies that emerge while the child is waiting there.
孩子被告知要待在房间里，他们让孩子独自和桌上的那颗棉花糖待在一起。孩子被要求坐在椅子上。然后研究人员等待观察孩子过多久会吃掉棉花糖。这里的想法是，孩子面前有一个好吃的零食，想必这零食很美味，孩子必须在现在就吃掉美味的零食，还是等待一会儿再吃，从而可能在15分钟后得到更大的奖励之间做出选择。没错。当你这样做时，孩子在等待的过程中会出现许多自发的策略。
It's common for kids to do things like to physically cover the marshmallow with their hands so that they don't see it to try to avoid the temptation of grabbing it and eating it. Children will sometimes try to look away from the marshmallow so they'll look up at the sky or something like this. They're in a room so it's not, I guess it's the ceiling, it's not a sky. Other strategies include trying to distract themselves by doing things like singing or making up a little story. Kids are very creative in coming up with ways to try to distract themselves. Aha.
孩子们通常会做一些事情，比如用手物理遮住棉花糖，这样他们就看不见它，试图避免伸手去拿并吃掉它的诱惑。孩子们有时会试图把目光从棉花糖上移开，所以他们会抬头看天空之类的东西。他们在房间里，所以我想那应该是天花板，不是天空。其他策略包括试图通过唱歌或编一个小故事来分散自己的注意力。孩子们在想方设法分散自己注意力方面非常有创造力。啊哈。
So, the kids pretty quickly, even though these are small kids, it sounds like the kids pretty quickly understood what was being asked of them, understood why it was difficult to do, and almost instantly came up with strategies to help them do this difficult thing. They did. I will also say though that the strategies that kids between the ages of three and five spontaneously come up with don't end up being very effective. So most of the kids end up eating the marshmallow very quickly. Kids wait about five or six minutes, something like that.
所以，孩子们很快就理解了对他们的要求，尽管他们年纪很小，他们似乎很快就理解了为什么这很难做到，并几乎立刻想出了帮助他们完成这件难事的策略。他们确实做到了。不过我也要说，三到五岁的孩子自发想出的策略最终并不是很有效。所以大多数孩子最终还是很快就吃掉了棉花糖。孩子们大约等待了五六分钟，差不多就是这样。
So they're not lasting very long. Walter Michelle, who died in 2018, said that children who were able to hold off eating the marshmallow demonstrated a capacity for something he called delayed gratification. He sensed it was an important skill in all sorts of domains and he wanted to see if he could teach kids strategies to exercise better self-control. He started to look for mental hacks that could help everyone, children and adults,
所以他们坚持的时间并不长。2018年去世的沃尔特·米歇尔（Walter Michelle）表示，那些能够忍住不吃棉花糖的孩子表现出了一种他称之为“延迟满足”的能力。他感觉到这在各种领域都是一项重要的技能，他想看看自己是否能教给孩子们锻炼更好自控力的策略。他开始寻找能帮助所有人（无论是儿童还是成人）的心理技巧，
stave off temptation. A lot of these strategies that were introduced were attentional manipulations, so teaching kids to imagine something like the later reward. So imagine what you're going to get later. He found that there were longer wait times when you introduced visualizations that didn't highlight the deliciousness of the marshmallow.
以抵御诱惑。所引入的许多策略都是注意力操纵，即教孩子们想象以后的奖励。所以想象一下你以后会得到什么。他发现，当你引入不强调棉花糖美味的视觉化想象时，等待时间会更长。
So picturing the marshmallow as a picture, for example, a picturing a frame around it was something that caused kids to be able to wait for longer. Whereas emphasizing the deliciousness, the chewiness of the marshmallow, imagining that was not helpful in helping kids wait, I was like, that tended to result in less long wait times. Do you have a sense on Walter Michelle's thinking on why he thought this trait would be useful, not just in the trivial game of waiting for five minutes to get the second marshmallow, but more generally in life?
例如，将棉花糖想象成一张图片，或者想象它周围有一个框架，这会让孩子们能够等待更长时间。而强调棉花糖的美味和嚼劲，想象这些反而无助于帮助孩子们等待，这往往会导致等待时间变短。你对沃尔特·米歇尔关于为什么他认为这种特质会有用的想法有什么了解吗？不仅仅是在等待五分钟以获得第二颗棉花糖这种琐碎的游戏中，而是在生活中更广泛的层面上？
I think that Walter Michelle's reasoning was largely intuitive. I think part of why people were very captivated by the marshmallow test and the videos is because they can relate to that. Everybody has been in a circumstance where they have something that would be better later if they could just resist some temptation. Now everybody can relate to that. just resist some temptation now, everybody can relate to that. What transformed the Marshmallow test from a fun experiment with cute preschoolers to a cultural phenomenon with enormous implications for social and public policy is what came next. In the decades that followed, Walter Michelle checked in on the kids from the original experiments.
我认为沃尔特·米歇尔的推理在很大程度上是直觉性的。我认为人们之所以被棉花糖实验和视频深深吸引，部分原因在于他们能产生共鸣。每个人都经历过这样的情况：如果能抵御某种诱惑，以后会得到更好的东西。现在每个人都能对此产生共鸣。是什么让棉花糖实验从一个可爱的学龄前儿童参与的有趣实验，变成了一个对社会和公共政策具有巨大影响的文化现象呢？是接下来发生的事情。在随后的几十年里，沃尔特·米歇尔对最初实验中的孩子们进行了回访。
He measured everything from their health outcomes to their academic performance. The point of all this tracking was to explore where the kids who were better able to resist temptation at the age of three had different life outcomes than the kids who ate the first marshmallow right away. There were a lot of findings suggesting that a child's ability to wait early in life, their ability to delight gratification, went on to predict the whole host of positive life outcomes. Ability to delight gratification was associated with lower body fat. So if you're the kind of kid who cannot eat this first marshmallow in the interest of getting to, maybe you grow up to be the kind
他测量了从他们的健康状况到学业表现的所有指标。所有这些追踪的目的是探讨三岁时更能抵御诱惑的孩子，是否比那些立刻吃掉第一颗棉花糖的孩子有不同的人生结果。有许多研究结果表明，孩子在生命早期等待的能力，即他们延迟满足的能力，预示着一系列积极的人生结果。延迟满足的能力与较低的体脂率有关。所以，如果你是那种为了得到更多奖励而不会吃掉第一颗棉花糖的孩子，也许你长大后会成为那种
of adult that cannot eat the piece of chocolate cake at a dinner party in the interest of achieving the physique that you want down the road, the ability to delay gratification in the marshmallow test specifically was predictive of social things and also bigger higher stakes outcomes. So not abusing drugs was associated with ability to wait for a second marshmallow. In another follow up, Walter Michelle found that kids who waited for the second marshmallow had higher SAT scores. Celeste, what was Walter Michelle's hypothesis about why delaying gratification at the age
在晚宴上为了保持理想身材而不会吃掉那块巧克力蛋糕的成年人。棉花糖实验中延迟满足的能力特别能预测社交方面以及更大、风险更高的结果。因此，不滥用药物与等待第二颗棉花糖的能力有关。在另一项后续研究中，沃尔特·米歇尔发现，等待第二颗棉花糖的孩子SAT分数更高。塞莱斯特，沃尔特·米歇尔关于为什么在
of three or the age of five could have effects on someone's body mass index or their SAT scores or their career outcomes 15, 20, 25 years down the road. The conceptual hypothesis was that self-control is causally responsible for the child's performance on the marshmallow test. And self-control is causally responsible for how well you do on all of these other factors in life. You need self-control to make friends. You need self-control to do well in school, to do well on your SAT, to avoid jail time and to stay thin.
三岁或五岁时延迟满足会对某人15、20、25年后的身体质量指数、SAT分数或职业成就产生影响的假设是什么？概念上的假设是，自控力是导致孩子在棉花糖实验中表现的原因。而自控力也是导致你在生活中所有其他方面表现如何的原因。你需要自控力来结交朋友。你需要自控力在学校取得好成绩，在SAT考试中取得好成绩，避免入狱并保持苗条。
And I think that's the best way to do it. Give me some sense of the impact of this test, not so much specifically on, it led to this policy or it led to that policy, but how people came to understand the test at a very broad level, not just researchers, not just scientists, looking at peer-reviewed journals, but ordinary people came to understand the test at a very broad level, not just researchers, not just scientists looking at peer-reviewed journals, but ordinary people. This test is commonly referenced in all sorts of pop culture formats. It's on sketch comedy shows and sitcoms and things like this.
我认为这是最好的做法。请让我了解一下这个测试的影响，不是具体到它导致了什么政策，而是人们在非常广泛的层面上是如何理解这个测试的，不仅仅是研究人员，不仅仅是阅读同行评审期刊的科学家，而是普通人。这个测试在各种流行文化形式中被普遍引用。它出现在小品喜剧节目、情景喜剧和类似的东西中。
It's also commonly cited in unexpected places like books on business management and how you should run a Company and then from a policy perspective. I think it also was attractive because it offered sort of magic Bullet for how you could combat Poverty as a how you could combat all of the challenges that face kids that are at the highest risk for the negative life outcomes. If it's self-control that is costly responsible for these negative life outcomes, all we have to do is train up their self-control and things will work out for them.
它也常被引用在一些意想不到的地方，比如商业管理书籍以及你应该如何经营一家公司，然后从政策角度来看。我认为它之所以吸引人，是因为它为如何对抗贫困，如何对抗那些面临负面人生结果风险最高的孩子所面临的所有挑战，提供了一种“灵丹妙药”。如果自控力是导致这些负面人生结果的原因，我们所要做的就是训练他们的自控力，事情就会好转。
I want to play you a little clip here, Celeste. This is Walter Michelle on the Colbert Report. You think that one who doesn't eat the marshmallow first, you found were more successful in life? The longer kids waited to get the two, generally, the more successful their lives turned out to be if they were consistent in how they continued in self-control over the life course. So we even need the SATs anymore if we've got the Marshmallows asked. Just get all the kids in the room, the kid who waits for the two Marshmallows right to the Ivy League.
我想给你放一段短片，塞莱斯特。这是科尔伯特报告（Colbert Report）上的沃尔特·米歇尔。你认为那些没有先吃棉花糖的人，你发现他们在生活中更成功？孩子们等待获得两颗棉花糖的时间越长，如果他们在整个生命过程中持续保持自控力，他们的人生通常就越成功。所以如果我们有了棉花糖测试，我们甚至还需要SAT吗？只要把所有的孩子都叫到房间里，等待两颗棉花糖的孩子直接去常春藤盟校。
There are. So you can see how this really captured the popular imagination here is Celeste. Oh wow. I somehow hadn't heard that before, but that's bringing back what I remember feeling the first time I heard about the marshmallow test. Those claims are big. The claim that it predicts your future, your ability to achieve the dreams that you want in life, those are big claims, those are big claims from, you know, a 20 minute experiment. All of us have grown up hearing stories about the importance of self-control, and most of us have seen the effects of self-control and a lack of self-control in our own lives.
确实如此。所以你可以看到这在塞莱斯特这里是如何真正捕捉到大众想象力的。哦，哇。我以前不知怎么没听说过，但这让我想起了我第一次听说棉花糖测试时的感受。那些主张很大。关于它能预测你的未来，你实现人生梦想的能力的说法，这些都是很大的主张，对于一个20分钟的实验来说，这些主张太大了。我们所有人在成长过程中都听过关于自控力重要性的故事，我们大多数人在自己的生活中都见过自控力和缺乏自控力的影响。
As I write these words, I'm regretting I had an extra large lunch two hours ago. It was delicious at the time, but now I feel uncomfortably full and sluggish. Walter Michele's Marshmallow experiments brought these lessons to life. They produced data that demonstrated a truism. Patients is a virtue, and those who practice patience will be rewarded. Not only with more marshmallows, but with better health, better careers, better lives. As we have seen so often on the show, however, human nature is exceedingly complex. Sweeping claims about human beings can fail to capture the nuances, the context, the
当我写下这些话时，我很后悔两个小时前吃了一顿超大份的午餐。当时吃的时候很美味，但现在我感到不舒服的饱胀和迟钝。沃尔特·米歇尔的棉花糖实验让这些教训变得生动起来。它们产生的数据证明了一个真理：耐心是一种美德，那些实践耐心的人会得到回报。不仅是得到更多的棉花糖，还有更好的健康、更好的职业、更好的人生。然而，正如我们在节目中经常看到的那样，人性极其复杂。关于人类的笼统主张往往无法捕捉到细微差别、背景以及
situations where rules break down. That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Before Celeste Kid became a psychologist, she was a determined high school student living in a small town east of New Orleans. Her dream was to graduate high school and attend college across the country in California. To make this happen, Celeste had to go through her own version of the Marshmallow test. I'm from a community that is literally on the swamp, there's alligators in the backyard,
规则失效的情况。这就是我们回来后要讨论的内容。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain），我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。在塞莱斯特·基德（Celeste Kid）成为心理学家之前，她是一名住在新奥尔良东部一个小镇上意志坚定的高中生。她的梦想是高中毕业并去全国另一端的加州上大学。为了实现这一目标，塞莱斯特必须经历她自己版本的棉花糖测试。我来自一个字面上就在沼泽地上的社区，后院里有短吻鳄，
it's everything you imagine. And I really wanted to go to college. I spent a lot of time in high school skipping out on things that my friends were doing in the interest of saving up money for college. One of Celeste's challenges had to do with restricting how much she indulged herself when it came to a particularly delicious New Orleans treat. Communal eating is very important in New Orleans and so it's common for you to be with a group of people and they say, okay, we're all gonna order pull boys
一切正如你所想象的那样。我真的很想上大学。我在高中花了很多时间放弃朋友们正在做的事情，为了存钱上大学。塞莱斯特面临的挑战之一是限制自己在面对一种特别美味的新奥尔良美食时的放纵程度。在新奥尔良，集体进食非常重要，所以你和一群人在一起很常见，他们会说，好吧，我们要一起点波仔三明治（Po'boys）
from, I was like my favorite places, parasols. And they're very delicious sandwiches. But when my friends would order, I would always say that I was not hungry. And actually, I was hungry, especially for pull boys, I was just eating peanut butter sandwiches on day old bread because it was cheap. I didn't want to spend the money on the Pope. I didn't want that to make the difference and the people who were very close to me who noticed this question whether or not I was being too
来自我最喜欢的地方，Parasols。它们是非常美味的三明治。但当我的朋友们点餐时，我总是说我不饿。其实我很饿，尤其是想吃波仔三明治，我只是在吃隔夜面包做的花生酱三明治，因为它很便宜。我不想把钱花在波仔三明治上。我不想让那成为区别，而那些与我非常亲近并注意到这一点的人，质疑我是否对自己太
restrictive with myself, whether I was putting all my hopes too far into the future when it wasn't even clear it was going to work out. And I had moments of wondering if that was true too. I had a boyfriend who said, is it really going to make the difference? Is this $20 going to make the difference between you getting to go to college? Or not, we had a big fight over it, actually.
苛刻了，是否把所有的希望都寄托在太遥远的未来，甚至不清楚是否会成功。我也有过怀疑那是否属实的时刻。我有一个男朋友说，这真的会有区别吗？这20美元真的会成为你能不能去上大学的区别吗？或者不，我们实际上为此大吵了一架。
And I said, it's not the $20. It's the $20 on the $20. It adds up. It adds up. And I know that it's not this one sacrifice I have to make a lot of them for it to work out and what if it is, what if it is this $20 that makes the difference between I can pay the tuition bill or not, I would be so sad if I was $20 short as like closer it is, the more painful it'll be if I don't make it.
我说，这不是20美元的问题。这是20美元加上20美元的问题。积少成多。积少成多。我知道这不是我必须做出的唯一牺牲，我必须做出很多牺牲才能成功，如果真的是这样呢，如果真的是这20美元决定了我能不能付得起学费呢？如果我差20美元，我会非常难过，越接近目标，如果我没做到，就会越痛苦。
The most difficult thing Celeste had to give up was the annual Mardi Gras Festival. Every year in New Orleans, social clubs come together and plan themed parades with elaborately decorated floats and costumes. All of the parades are thrown by their called crunes, which are essentially social clubs that get together and plan for most of the year what the parade theme is going to be, what each of the folks is going to look like. Obviously, that takes a lot of time.
塞莱斯特不得不放弃的最困难的事情是年度狂欢节（Mardi Gras Festival）。每年在新奥尔良，社交俱乐部都会聚在一起，计划带有精心装饰的花车和服装的主题游行。所有的游行都是由他们所谓的“克鲁”（Crunes）举办的，这些本质上是社交俱乐部，他们聚在一起计划一年中大部分时间游行的主题是什么，每一辆花车看起来会是什么样。显然，这需要花费大量时间。
It's very intricate work. Each parade is a one-in-a-lifetime experience. That you're there for or you're not, so. In her junior year of high school, Celeste was offered a babysitting gig for a bunch of families attending a big party called a Mardi Gras-Bas. But all her friends were going to the parade that night. Celeste wanted desperately to go to. But... Junior year I was thinking about not having enough for college and it was very important that I get as much as I could. So I chose to babysit for the families that
这是非常复杂的工作。每一场游行都是一生一次的体验。你要么在那里，要么不在，所以。在高三那年，塞莱斯特被提供了一份为一群参加名为“狂欢节舞会”（Mardi Gras-Bas）的大型派对的家庭做保姆的工作。但那天晚上她所有的朋友都要去参加游行。塞莱斯特非常想去。但是……高三那年，我一直在想钱不够上大学，我尽可能多地赚钱非常重要。所以我选择为那些
were going to the Mardi Gras Ball. I love babysitting. But sitting there after the kids went bed that night, I was wondering about what I had missed as one does when one skips out on something very exciting. I was feeling a little bit sorry for myself. But then when the families came back, they had had a really, really good time and they tipped me a few hundred dollars. They tipped me enough that I had to check the next morning to make sure that that's the amount that they meant to tip me. And yes, I actually don't think it was, but I think it was too. They were graceful
要去参加狂欢节舞会的家庭做保姆。我喜欢做保姆。但那天晚上孩子们睡着后坐在那里，我一直在想我错过了什么，就像人们错过了一些非常令人兴奋的事情时那样。我当时觉得有点可怜自己。但当那些家庭回来时，他们玩得非常非常开心，他们给了我几百美元的小费。他们给的小费多到我第二天早上不得不检查一下，以确保那是他们打算给我的金额。是的，我其实不认为那是，但我认为确实是。他们很优雅，
and they didn't want to say like that was actually an accident. Give that, they knew I was saving for college. So you eventually get to UC Santa Cruz for your undergraduate studies. And I'm wondering when you got there, did you have a sense that the things that you had foregone that it was worth it to actually be at UC Santa Cruz? Did it meet your expectations? I could not believe when I first arrived at the campus
他们不想说那其实是个意外。鉴于他们知道我在为上大学存钱。所以你最终去了加州大学圣克鲁兹分校（UC Santa Cruz）进行本科学习。我想知道当你到达那里时，你是否觉得你所放弃的东西，为了真正来到加州大学圣克鲁兹分校是值得的？它符合你的期望吗？当我第一次到达校园时，我简直不敢相信
and I saw the giant red woods. The campus is beautiful. I could not believe I had gotten that far and it had worked out. Then when I started taking the classes and I could take as many as I wanted and there were so many ones that were interesting and I had all of my day to take the classes I was delighted with my life choices up until that point. So that was worth it. That was worth it in the long term. It was painful in the short term. Now, as you listen to Celeste's story, you might conclude she is the post-church child for Walter Michelle's marshmallow test. Forgo delicious and tempting treats? Check. Do the hard thing now in exchange for the better thing tomorrow? Check.
我看到了巨大的红杉树。校园很美。我简直不敢相信我走到了这一步，而且一切都成功了。然后当我开始上课时，我可以随心所欲地选修课程，有那么多有趣的课程，我整天都在上课，我对到目前为止的人生选择感到非常高兴。所以那是值得的。从长远来看，那是值得的。在短期内是痛苦的。现在，当你听塞莱斯特的故事时，你可能会得出结论，她是沃尔特·米歇尔棉花糖测试的代言人。放弃美味和诱人的零食？做到。现在做困难的事情以换取明天更好的事情？做到。
Delay gratification and do well in life? Check and check. But not long after she arrived in California, Celeste had an experience that changed the way she thought about self-control. She was working at a family emergency center, a place where parents and their children could access resources during difficult times. Celeste of course, liked to spend time with kids. It's hard to explain what the culture of an emergency family shelter is like. There's a lot of hard stuff that's going on. There's parents that have substance abuse issues. There are parents that are incarcerated unexpectedly. Working at an emergency family shelter also means that you
延迟满足并在生活中取得成功？做到且做到。但在她到达加州后不久，塞莱斯特经历了一件事，改变了她对自控力的看法。她在一家家庭紧急救助中心工作，这是一个父母和孩子在困难时期可以获得资源的地方。塞莱斯特当然喜欢和孩子们待在一起。很难解释紧急家庭收容所的文化是什么样的。有很多困难的事情正在发生。有父母有药物滥用问题。有父母意外入狱。在紧急家庭收容所工作也意味着你
are opting into getting sick a whole lot just because it's the people are living in harsh conditions. So in some senses you would think that it should be hard, but working there was a delight because the kids are so cool. Celeste had a job tutoring some of the older kids at the shelter, but she developed a special bond with a preschooler named JoJo. One of the first interactions I had with Jojo, she had just told me she had a lollipop and just as she was about to put it in her mouth, I was turned towards the kids that I was about to tutor. Out of the corner of my eye,
选择经常生病，仅仅因为人们生活在恶劣的条件下。所以在某种意义上，你会认为这应该很困难，但在这里工作是一种乐趣，因为孩子们太酷了。塞莱斯特有一份辅导收容所里一些大孩子的工作，但她与一个名叫乔乔（JoJo）的学龄前儿童建立了特殊的联系。我与乔乔的第一次互动之一，她刚告诉我她有一根棒棒糖，就在她正要把棒棒糖放进嘴里时，我转向了我正要辅导的孩子们。在我的眼角余光里，
I saw another kid come bounding down the stairs and grab the lollipop from her hand right before it goes into her mouth. I'd worked in a daycare before and I was expecting her to burst into tears. So I instinctively whipped around, expecting that she would need some comfort for this upsetting thing happening. And to my surprise, she didn't have any reaction at all. She continued walking like she had not had a lollipop in her hand at all.
我看到另一个孩子从楼梯上跳下来，在棒棒糖进入她嘴里之前从她手中抢走了它。我以前在托儿所工作过，我以为她会大哭起来。所以我本能地猛地转过身，以为她会因为这件令人沮丧的事情发生而需要一些安慰。令我惊讶的是，她根本没有任何反应。她继续走着，就像她手里从来没有拿过棒棒糖一样。
Celeste was struck by JoJo's reaction. The fact she didn't need comforting was worrisome. I thought, oh no, that's a sign of something that's gone wrong. I was like, she should have an emotional reaction. Maybe she has some sort of psychological damage, some emotional stunting or some dissociation or something else. Maybe there's something wrong with her emotionally or maybe it's a memory problem. Maybe she didn't remember that she had the lollipop.
塞莱斯特被乔乔的反应震惊了。她不需要安慰的事实令人担忧。我想，哦不，那是出了问题的迹象。我想，她应该有情绪反应。也许她有什么心理创伤，或者某种情绪发育迟缓，或者某种解离，或者其他什么。也许她在情感上有什么问题，或者也许这是一个记忆问题。也许她不记得她拿过棒棒糖了。
I thought something was wrong with her. But within a short time of working at the shelter, Celeste realized why JoJo had not been upset. I never had a discussion with her about the lollipop because it didn't take long before I figured out that it was me that made the error. It wasn't upsetting because it was very expected. It's very, very common for a bunch of kids that don't have a lot of adult supervision around to steal stuff from each other. Jojo was little and she knew she was little. So she knew that there was a timer on her, putting that olive pop in her mouth and she took a little too long.
我以为她出了什么问题。但在收容所工作没多久，塞莱斯特就意识到为什么乔乔没有难过。我从来没有和她讨论过棒棒糖的事，因为没过多久我就发现是我犯了错。这并不令人沮丧，因为这是非常预料之中的。对于一群没有太多成人监督的孩子来说，互相偷东西是非常非常普遍的。乔乔很小，她知道自己很小。所以她知道把棒棒糖放进嘴里是有时间限制的，而她花的时间太长了。
And so it wasn't upsetting to her in part because it wasn't unexpected. It was me that made the reasoning error and I will remember that forever. Shortly after that moment with JoJo, another incident occurred that made a powerful impression on Celeste. I was there for a church group coming and giving out toys to the kids. They lined them up, they gave many of them toys one at a time and a common response that the kids at the shelter had to getting these new toys was to immediately break them and the church volunteers that were giving them out. I heard them
所以这并没有让她感到难过，部分原因是因为这并不出乎意料。是我犯了推理错误，我会永远记住这一点。在与乔乔（JoJo）发生那一幕后不久，又发生了一件事，给塞莱斯特（Celeste）留下了深刻的印象。当时我在那里，一个教会团体来给孩子们分发玩具。他们让孩子们排好队，一个接一个地给他们发玩具。收容所里的孩子们在拿到这些新玩具后的常见反应是立刻把它们弄坏，而那些分发玩具的教会志愿者们，我听到他们
talking about how these kids they were not grateful and I mean I can't even some of the things that were said were so awful that I opted not to encode them. But the suggestion was that these kids deserve the situation that they're in, that they're the offspring of people that are like this that aren't grateful, and that's why they're here.
在谈论这些孩子是多么不知感恩。我是说，我甚至无法复述，因为有些话实在太难听了，我选择不去记录。但他们的暗示是，这些孩子落到今天这个地步是罪有应得，他们是那些同样不知感恩的人的后代，所以他们才会在这个地方。
And I found that really upsetting because being there and spending time with these kids and understanding what their daily life was like, it was very clear to me why they were breaking the toys. At this shelter, each family got just one basket that they could use to store things and it was about the size of a shoe box. If you imagine that you are in that situation,
我感到非常难过，因为身处其中，与这些孩子相处，了解他们的日常生活，我很清楚他们为什么要弄坏玩具。在这个收容所里，每个家庭只有一个用来存放物品的篮子，大约鞋盒那么大。如果你想象一下你处于那种境地，
you have one shoe box worth of storage for your whole family, what's going in that box? It have one shoebox worth of storage for your whole family. What's going in that box? It's like paper documents that you need as it gets IDs. It's maybe some hygiene things. It's toothpaste and toothbrushes and it's medications. It's not a big doll.
你全家所有的储物空间只有一个鞋盒那么大，你会往盒子里放什么？你全家所有的储物空间只有一个鞋盒那么大。你会往盒子里放什么？那里面放的是你需要的纸质文件，比如身份证件。可能还有一些卫生用品。比如牙膏、牙刷和药品。那里面放不下大玩偶。
A big bulky doll is not going to make it into that box at the end of the day. And these kids knew that. And so all kids, I think, have thoughts like what would this doll look like with its head pulled off? What do they feel like to pull off the head of this doll and what prevents some kids from pulling off the head of their doll is the expectation that they're going to be able to play with it tomorrow.
一个又大又笨重的玩偶最终是放不进那个盒子的。这些孩子心里很清楚。所以我想，所有的孩子都会有这样的想法：如果把这个玩偶的头扯下来会是什么样？扯下玩偶的头是什么感觉？而阻止一些孩子扯下玩偶头的原因，是他们预期明天还能继续玩它。
And these kids just didn't have that expectation. So hearing these moralistic judgments of these kids from people that didn't understand, they weren't going to get to play with the doll tomorrow. So there's no point in preserving it. You should play with it hard. You should make decisions that give you satisfaction right now. If you can't count on what's going to be available to you tomorrow, then to see these kids get judged for them was upsetting and also influential in shaping
而这些孩子根本没有这种预期。所以，听到那些不了解情况的人对这些孩子做出道德评判，说他们明天玩不到那个玩偶了，所以保存它毫无意义。你应该用力玩它。你应该做出能让你当下感到满足的决定。如果你无法指望明天还能拥有什么，那么看到这些孩子因此受到评判，不仅令人难过，也对我塑造
my understanding of human behavior at large. The summer after Celeste graduated from college, she decided to take some linguistics courses at Stanford. She became friends with a graduate student who was in several of her classes. One day, they took a walk through campus. So we were walking through the halls and discussing, you know, things like the Stanford prison experiment and the marshmallow task came up. And I had never heard of it before.
对人类行为的整体理解产生了影响。塞莱斯特大学毕业后的那个夏天，她决定在斯坦福大学修读一些语言学课程。她和一位同上几门课的研究生交上了朋友。有一天，他们走在校园里。我们走在走廊里，讨论着像斯坦福监狱实验之类的话题，然后提到了棉花糖实验。我以前从未听说过这个实验。
He was surprised I hadn't heard of it before. And he explained that the Marshmallow test as being something that you could administer to a kid early in life that could tell you whether or not they were going to achieve great things. He described it as a test where you give kids a choice, a very simple choice between one marshmallow now, or if they can wait for the researcher to leave and then come back, then they can have two marshmallows if they don't eat the first marshmallow. My response to that initially was thinking, oh no, I was
他很惊讶我以前没听说过。他解释说，棉花糖实验是一种可以在孩子幼年时期进行的测试，可以判断他们未来是否能取得伟大的成就。他将其描述为一种给孩子选择的测试，一个非常简单的选择：现在吃一颗棉花糖，或者如果他们能等研究人员离开再回来，那么如果不吃第一颗棉花糖，他们就能得到两颗。我最初的反应是想，哦不，我当时
thinking about JoJo, I was thinking about the other kids at the shelter, and the first place my head went is knowing that these kids I was working with would eat that first marshmallow right away. I don't think I'd even be able to get my hand up. And that made me sad because I was there trying to help them avoid all of these negative outcomes he was saying were predicted by waiting for that second marshmallow. Celeste was training to be a psychologist. Her experience at the shelter prompted her to ask herself a provocative question. Was it possible that Walter Michelle, one of the giants in the field of psychology, had missed something very, very important?
在想乔乔，在想收容所里的其他孩子，我脑海中浮现的第一个念头就是，我知道我共事的这些孩子肯定会立刻吃掉第一颗棉花糖。我觉得我甚至连手都举不起来。这让我感到难过，因为我当时正试图帮助他们避免他所说的那些因等待第二颗棉花糖而产生的负面结果。塞莱斯特当时正在接受心理学培训。她在收容所的经历促使她问自己一个发人深省的问题。有没有可能，心理学领域的泰斗之一沃尔特·米歇尔（Walter Mischel）遗漏了一些非常、非常重要的东西？
One of the core ideas in social psychology is that the social and the psychological are inextricably tied up with one another. We think we are the captains of our ships and the masters of our own destiny. We think we choose to be good or bad when confronted by an ethical situation. Now there is certainly truth in that, our thoughts and preferences and choices do shape our behavior in powerful ways. But what most of us underestimate is the extent to which the social world shapes the thoughts inside our heads.
社会心理学的核心思想之一是，社会因素与心理因素是密不可分的。我们认为自己是命运的船长，是自己命运的主宰。我们认为在面对道德困境时，我们可以选择做个好人或坏人。当然，这确实有道理，我们的思想、偏好和选择确实以强大的方式塑造了我们的行为。但我们大多数人低估了社会环境塑造我们大脑中思想的程度。
Walter Michal's study, looking at the kids of well-to-do families at Stanford, was being used to explain the behavior of kids growing up in very different contexts. Was that fair? Even more importantly, was that accurate? The crux of the marshmallow test interpretation, that is most popular, which is that self-control is causally responsible for your success or failure to achieve success in life hinges on The individual and whether the individual has a particular ability or not and if they don't have a particular ability The implication is they're not going to do well in life and also there's an implication that it's their fault If they were a different way they would deserve to do well
沃尔特·米歇尔的研究观察的是斯坦福大学富裕家庭的孩子，而这项研究却被用来解释在截然不同的环境下成长的孩子的行为。这公平吗？更重要的是，这准确吗？棉花糖实验最流行的解读的核心在于：自控力是导致你人生成功或失败的根本原因，这取决于个人，取决于个人是否具备某种能力。如果他们不具备某种能力，暗示的意思就是他们的人生不会成功，而且还暗示这是他们自己的错。如果他们换一种方式，他们本应值得成功。
If they are not that way they get what they get I if they are not that way, they get what they get. I recognize that there was an alternative hypothesis that I thought there was good evidence for even in Walter Michelle's own data. And the alternative hypothesis is that it's not that marshmallow test is measuring self-control and self-control is causally responsible for the long-term outcomes.
如果他们不是那样，他们就只能得到那样的结果。我意识到存在另一种假设，我认为即使在沃尔特·米歇尔自己的数据中也有很好的证据支持。另一种假设是，棉花糖实验测量的并不是自控力，也不是自控力导致了长期的结果。
The alternative is what the Marshmallow test is testing is a child's expectations about how stable and reliable the world is. Put another way, your ability to delay gratification in the Marshmallow test doesn't just depend on your capacity for self-control. It depends on whether you believe there really is a second marshmallow waiting for you if you hold off eating the first. As Celeste pursued a PhD at the University of Rochester, she designed a marshmallow
另一种可能是，棉花糖实验测试的是孩子对世界是否稳定可靠的预期。换句话说，你在棉花糖实验中延迟满足的能力，不仅仅取决于你的自控能力。它还取决于你是否相信，如果你忍住不吃第一颗，真的会有第二颗棉花糖在等着你。当塞莱斯特在罗切斯特大学攻读博士学位时，她设计了一个棉花糖
test of her own. We recruited three to five-year-old kids, and then we randomly assigned them to one of two conditions. They were either assigned to the reliable condition or the unreliable condition, and in advance of them doing the marshmallow test, we gave them an experience, a set of evidence about whether or not they could count on future promised rewards being delivered.
实验。我们招募了三到五岁的孩子，然后将他们随机分配到两种条件之一。他们要么被分配到可靠条件组，要么被分配到不可靠条件组。在进行棉花糖实验之前，我们让他们经历了一件事，提供了一组证据，让他们了解是否可以指望未来承诺的奖励能够兑现。
Celeste and her colleague Holly Pahmeri told the kids they would be doing an art project. They could choose to use some regular crayons and begin that project immediately. But if they waited a few minutes, Holly would run out and come back with markers and some fancy art supplies. When we presented kids with this choice, just like in the marshmallow test, kids always chose that they would like the second bigger set of art supplies instead. Holly then left them alone in the room under the premise that she was going to get the bigger set of art supplies instead.
塞莱斯特和她的同事霍莉·帕赫梅里（Holly Pahmeri）告诉孩子们他们要做一个艺术项目。他们可以选择使用一些普通的蜡笔，立即开始那个项目。但如果他们等几分钟，霍莉就会跑出去，带回马克笔和一些精美的艺术用品。当我们给孩子们这个选择时，就像在棉花糖实验中一样，孩子们总是选择他们想要第二套更大的艺术用品。然后，霍莉以去拿那套更大的艺术用品为由，把他们单独留在房间里。
And then whether or not she came in with them, depending upon the condition that the child was assigned to. For kids assigned to the reliable condition, Holly reappeared in a few minutes with a nicer out supplies. The kids received a lesson that waiting did produce good things. But for the kids in the unreliable group, Holly would leave the room. And then when she would come back, she would apologize to the kid and say, I'm very sorry. I thought I had a big set of art supplies,
然后，根据孩子被分配到的条件，她是否会带着东西回来。对于被分配到可靠条件组的孩子，霍莉几分钟后带着更好的艺术用品出现了。孩子们学到了一课：等待确实能带来好东西。但对于不可靠组的孩子，霍莉会离开房间。当她回来时，她会向孩子道歉，说：非常抱歉。我以为我有大套的艺术用品，
but it turns out I don't. But let me help you use these crayons instead and she would help them open the container to get out the crayons and use that art supply. And conceptually, what were you trying to do here, Celeste, with these two conditions of the kids who basically waited for the better art supplies and got it and the kids who waited for the better art supplies and didn't get it. Conceptually we wanted children to generate different expectations depending upon what they had experienced in this specific context. So we wanted the kids in the reliable condition to generate the expectation that if I wait, it is worth it, it will pay off, and we wanted kids in the unreliable condition to have
但结果我没有。不过让我帮你用这些蜡笔吧。然后她会帮他们打开盒子，拿出蜡笔，使用那些艺术用品。从概念上讲，塞莱斯特，你在这里试图通过这两种条件做什么？那些基本上等待了更好的艺术用品并得到了的孩子，以及那些等待了更好的艺术用品却没得到的孩子。从概念上讲，我们希望孩子们根据他们在特定情境中的经历产生不同的预期。所以我们希望可靠条件组的孩子产生这样的预期：如果我等待，这是值得的，会有回报；而我们希望不可靠条件组的孩子产生
the expectation that if I wait, it is not worth it, it will not pay off, so that we could tell what the impact of expectations was on the Marshm marshmallow test that we did after the art project task. The marshmallow test was part two of the study. After the kids finished their art project, Holly announced that it was snack time. Holly would say, you can have this one marshmallow now, or if you want to wait for me to go into the room. If you don't eat this one, you can have two marshmallows instead.
这样的预期：如果我等待，这是不值得的，不会有回报。这样我们就能看出预期对我们在艺术项目任务之后进行的棉花糖实验有什么影响。棉花糖实验是研究的第二部分。在孩子们完成艺术项目后，霍莉宣布吃零食的时间到了。霍莉会说：你现在可以吃这一颗棉花糖，或者如果你想等我进房间。如果你不吃这一颗，你就可以得到两颗棉花糖。
And with that premise, that's the classic marshmallow test. She cleared all of the art supplies out of the room and left the child alone with the single marshmallow on the table. And just like in the classic marshmallow test, we measured and waited to see how long they would wait before they ate the marshmallow. And what did you find? We found that there was a big difference between the kids in the unreliable condition versus the reliable condition. In the unreliable condition, kids were much more likely to eat the marshmallow. They waited an average of about three minutes.
带着这个前提，这就是经典的棉花糖实验。她把房间里所有的艺术用品都清理干净，让孩子独自一人面对桌上的那颗棉花糖。就像在经典的棉花糖实验中一样，我们测量并等待，看他们在吃掉棉花糖之前会等多久。你发现了什么？我们发现不可靠条件组和可靠条件组的孩子之间存在巨大差异。在不可靠条件组中，孩子们更有可能吃掉棉花糖。他们平均等待了大约三分钟。
That's very different from what happened in the reliable condition. In the reliable condition, kids waited four times as long. They waited on average 12 minutes before eating the marshmallow. They were less likely to eat the marshmallow in the end in that condition as well. At one level, you could say the results were entirely unsurprising. If someone tells you to wait five minutes and they will be a wonderful treat at the end, and you wait five minutes, only to be told no treat is forthcoming, how would you respond if this person told you to wait another five minutes for a new treat?
这与在可靠条件下的情况截然不同。在可靠条件下，孩子们等待的时间是原来的四倍。他们平均等待了12分钟才吃掉棉花糖。在这种情况下，他们最终吃掉棉花糖的可能性也更小。从某种程度上说，你可以说这些结果完全在意料之中。如果有人告诉你等五分钟，最后会给你一份美妙的款待，而你等了五分钟，结果却被告知没有款待，那么如果这个人让你再等五分钟去换取一份新的款待，你会作何反应？
You might say something along the lines of Fool me once shame on you fool me twice shame on me It only makes sense to wait for the second marshmallow if you expect the second marshmallow to arrive If you don't expect for the second marshmallow to arrive you should eat the first marshmallow In fact, it would almost be foolish for you not to eat the first marshmallow, because if you don't eat it, someone else might come along and eat it, while you're waiting for the second marshmallow. That's right.
你可能会说类似这样的话：骗我一次是你不对，骗我两次就是我不对了。只有当你预期第二个棉花糖会到来时，等待它才是有意义的。如果你不指望第二个棉花糖会到来，你就应该吃掉第一个。事实上，如果你不吃掉第一个棉花糖，几乎是愚蠢的，因为如果你不吃，别人可能会在你等待第二个棉花糖的时候过来把它吃掉。没错。
That's like the jojo thing might happen. Like, if you don't put the lollipop in your mouth, right away, somebody else might come along and take it. You should eat that first marshmallow, if you think there is no point in waiting for a second. You know, I've always wondered what Walter Michelle would make of the way his test has come to be received in the world today, Celeste. I'm not quite sure he anticipated it would take off the way it did and that people would draw the implications that they did. I mean, at various points, he would say,
这就像可能会发生那种“乔乔”效应。比如，如果你不马上把棒棒糖放进嘴里，别人可能会过来把它拿走。如果你认为等待第二个棉花糖毫无意义，你就应该吃掉第一个。你知道，我一直很好奇沃尔特·米歇尔会如何看待他的测试在当今世界所受到的评价，塞莱斯特。我不确定他是否预料到它会以这种方式流行起来，并被人们引申出那样的含义。我的意思是，在不同的场合，他会说，
you know, this is a 15-minute test, you can't draw too much into a 15-minute test. Now he did do the longitudinal studies finding these long-term effects But I'm wondering do you feel like your test has been a corrective not just to the marshmallow test, but the Impact the cultural valence of the marshmallow test in the larger world. I don't know if I can speak to that in the larger world? I don't know if I can speak to that. Walter Michelle was invested in the idea that self-control is an important virtue to develop. That's also largely the point of the book that he wrote about the Marshmallow Test.
你知道，这是一个15分钟的测试，你不能从一个15分钟的测试中得出太多结论。现在他确实做了纵向研究，发现了这些长期影响。但我很好奇，你是否觉得你的测试不仅是对棉花糖测试的一种修正，也是对棉花糖测试在更大世界中的文化价值的一种修正？我不知道我是否能谈论那个更大的世界？我不知道我是否能谈论那个。沃尔特·米歇尔致力于这样一个观点：自控力是一种值得培养的重要美德。这也是他所写的关于棉花糖测试那本书的主要观点。
At the same time, I don't disagree with any of the premises in the original studies. It was inherently acknowledging that children's delaying gratification or not is a flexible system that can be changed depending upon the attentional strategy that you hand them. So I don't think that work captured the minds of people in the same way that the promise of the predictive power of the Marshmallow test from the longitudinal correlations did later. But Walter Michelle, to my knowledge, wasn't opposed to the idea that the system is flexible. There are certainly times where delaying gratification pays off, work hard and save your money, and you improve your options when it's time to go to college.
与此同时，我并不反对原始研究中的任何前提。它本质上承认，儿童是否延迟满足是一个灵活的系统，可以根据你提供给他们的注意力策略而改变。所以我认为，那项工作并没有像后来纵向相关性所带来的棉花糖测试的预测能力承诺那样，以同样的方式吸引人们的注意力。但据我所知，沃尔特·米歇尔并不反对系统是灵活的这一观点。当然，在某些时候，延迟满足是有回报的，努力工作并存钱，当你上大学时，你的选择就会更多。
Study hard today, and you're likely to do better in your exams tomorrow. Tolerate the discomfort that comes with learning a new musical instrument and you might produce beautiful music in a few years. Patients and prudence can be virtues. But in the popular understanding of the Marshmello test, many people concluded self-control was a purely personal virtue. You had it or you didn't have it. It was about you, the individual. Celeste's reconception of the test underscores that core idea and social psychology. The context matters.
今天努力学习，明天考试成绩可能会更好。忍受学习新乐器带来的不适，几年后你可能会创作出美妙的音乐。耐心和审慎可以是美德。但在对棉花糖测试的普遍理解中，许多人得出结论：自控力纯粹是一种个人美德。你有它，或者你没有它。这是关于你，这个个体。塞莱斯特对该测试的重新构想强调了社会心理学中的那个核心理念：环境很重要。
Self-control is not just about what happens inside our heads. Our capacity for self-control is shaped by whether we live in a safe and predictable world or a dangerous and unpredictable world. Take the kids from the Stanford nursery that Walter Michelle was studying and put them in an unpredictable environment for a few weeks, and they too might behave in ways
自控力不仅仅关乎我们大脑内部发生的事情。我们自控的能力取决于我们是生活在一个安全且可预测的世界，还是一个危险且不可预测的世界。把沃尔特·米歇尔研究的斯坦福幼儿园的孩子们放在一个不可预测的环境中几周，他们也可能会表现出
that would appear impulsive and short-sighted. And they too might behave in ways that would appear impulsive and short-sighted. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Jacqueline Rifkin is named after her grandfather, Jack. We don't know for sure how Jack would have performed on Walter Michelle's Marshmallow test, but we can't take an educated guess. He would not have eaten that first marshmallow. He fought for the US and World War II. He actually helped liberate some of the concentration camps.
看起来冲动和短视的行为。他们也可能会表现出看起来冲动和短视的行为。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。杰奎琳·里夫金是以她祖父杰克的名字命名的。我们不确定杰克在沃尔特·米歇尔的棉花糖测试中表现如何，但我们可以做一个有根据的猜测。他不会吃掉那个第一个棉花糖。他曾为美国参加二战。他实际上帮助解放了一些集中营。
And his story, I think, was really instrumental in sort of how I was raised and how I see the world, even though I never got to meet him. So when he got back from the war, he met my grandmother and they got married. And their plan was to be really frugal, save up a lot of money, be sort of conservative financially, and then when he retired, they would travel the world. And so my mom grew up with this very sort of low risk frugal kind of way of living with this plan for ultimately my pop-ups retirement. The sad part of the story is that they never really got to bear the fruits of all of this saving because my pop-up was diagnosed with cancer in his 60s and he actually passed away just a few months after the diagnosis.
我认为他的故事对我成长的方式以及我看待世界的方式确实起到了很大的作用，尽管我从未见过他。所以当他从战争中回来时，他遇到了我的祖母，他们结婚了。他们的计划是非常节俭，存很多钱，在经济上保持保守，然后等他退休后，他们就去环游世界。所以我妈妈在成长过程中，生活方式非常低风险且节俭，并为我外公的退休做了这个计划。这个故事悲伤的部分在于，他们从未真正享受到所有这些储蓄的成果，因为我外公在60多岁时被诊断出患有癌症，他在确诊后仅几个月就去世了。
And so my mom sort of told me that over the years, her mom, my mom, who lived for many years after that, always kind of regretted the way that they had structured their lives. And my mom was always really vocal when I was growing up that obviously responsibility and fragality and prudence are great virtues, but also not to save everything for later all of life's pleasures.
所以我妈妈多年来一直告诉我，她的妈妈，也就是我外婆，在之后活了很多年，一直很后悔他们安排生活的方式。我妈妈在我成长过程中一直非常直言不讳地说，责任、节俭和审慎当然是伟大的美德，但也不要为了未来而牺牲掉所有的生活乐趣。
It's a lesson that Jacqueline has tried to take to heart. And yet, despite her mother's warnings and her grandmother's regrets, she regularly notices that she is very much her grandfather's granddaughter. So I bought a white blouse from Old Navy several years ago. And if there's something about Old Navy, it's that it's casual and it's not super expensive. I think it was probably 1999. And I didn't wear it right away, which is something that I am absolutely kind of a chronic delayer of new clothes. And so I didn't wear it, you know, for school,
这是一个杰奎琳试图铭记在心的教训。然而，尽管有她母亲的警告和她祖母的遗憾，她经常注意到她确实是她祖父的孙女。几年前，我在Old Navy买了一件白色衬衫。Old Navy的东西有一种特点，就是休闲且不贵。我想那大概是1999年。我没有马上穿它，我绝对是一个慢性拖延穿新衣服的人。所以我没有穿它，你知道，为了上学，
I didn't wear it to run errands. And somehow over time, it became a date night shirt that I didn't wear. And then it became a job interview shirt that I didn't wear. And I think after a few years, the shirt was essentially no longer in style, and I just had to donate it.
我没有穿它去跑腿。不知何故，随着时间的推移，它变成了一件我没穿过的约会衬衫。然后它变成了一件我没穿过的面试衬衫。我想几年后，这件衬衫基本上已经过时了，我只好把它捐了。
And it goes back to zero, right? The person who buys it now for them, it's like a workout shirt. But for me, we had gone on this whole journey together where this simple old Navy shirt had sort of transformed into like a talisman, a fashion talisman. You've likely experienced some version of this in your own life. If it's not a new shirt hanging in your closet, maybe it's an unused gift card to a local restaurant. Jacqueline is now a marketing professor at Cornell University. She and her
它又回到了零，对吧？现在买它的人，对他们来说，这就像一件运动衫。但对我来说，我们一起经历了一段旅程，这件简单的Old Navy衬衫已经变成了一种护身符，一种时尚护身符。你可能在自己的生活中也经历过类似的事情。如果不是衣柜里挂着一件新衬衫，也许是一张当地餐馆未使用的礼品卡。杰奎琳现在是康奈尔大学的市场营销教授。她和她的
colleague, Jonah Berger at the University of Pennsylvania, have examined what keeps people from enjoying the things they own. We were really interested in these things that we all own around the house that we like and we're not trying to get rid of but we're also not using them. So I think a bottle of wine is an example that can resonate with everyone. Jonah had socks that he always thought about. I had a blouse that I always thought about. They were perfectly fine. They weren't special. They were kind of just normal. But for some reason, they kept sticking around. We weren't using, but we weren't donating. And so what we found through a series of experiments there was that sometimes people forgo usage.
同事，宾夕法尼亚大学的乔纳·伯格，研究了是什么阻止人们享受他们拥有的东西。我们对家里那些我们拥有、喜欢且不想扔掉，但又没在使用的东西非常感兴趣。所以我认为一瓶酒是一个能引起每个人共鸣的例子。乔纳有他一直想穿的袜子。我有一件一直想穿的衬衫。它们完全没问题。它们并不特别。它们只是很普通。但出于某种原因，它们一直留着。我们没在使用，但也没捐掉。所以我们通过一系列实验发现，有时人们放弃了使用。
They say, I'm not going to open the wine tonight. I'm not going to bust out the candle and light it for the first time tonight. And even though it's not our intention, we kind of feel like we're saving it. So it goes from not now to not now and later. And the more that we feel like we're saving, the more special that product becomes. And so we enter this spiral, we call it a specialist spiral in the paper, whereby people are foregoing usage for something normal. it feels a little bit more special. So now we wanna find a slightly better occasion for it.
他们说，我今晚不开这瓶酒。我今晚不拿出蜡烛第一次点燃它。即使这不是我们的本意，我们也觉得我们在节省它。所以它从“不是现在”变成了“现在和以后都不行”。我们越觉得我们在节省，那个产品就变得越特别。所以我们进入了这个螺旋，我们在论文中称之为“特别螺旋”，人们放弃了对普通物品的使用。它感觉稍微特别了一点。所以现在我们想为它找一个稍微好一点的场合。
So then we forego usage again, becomes a little bit more special. Okay, now I need to find an even better occasion for it. And over time, this perfectly normal pair of socks becomes a treasure. That is only worthy for your wedding night. a treasure that is only worthy for your wedding night. Notice that the specialness spiral works like a ratchet. Each time you forego using the shirt, the specialness of the shirt reaches a new threshold. The next time you think of using the shirt, the bar is now even higher than it was the last time.
所以我们再次放弃使用，它变得更特别了一点。好吧，现在我需要为它找一个更好的场合。随着时间的推移，这双完全普通的袜子变成了一件宝藏。只有在你的新婚之夜才配得上使用。一件只有在你的新婚之夜才配得上使用的宝藏。请注意，特别螺旋的作用就像一个棘轮。每次你放弃使用这件衬衫，衬衫的特别程度就达到了一个新的阈值。下一次你想到使用这件衬衫时，门槛比上次更高了。
That's exactly what happens. And we even asked people flat out, you know, what is the right occasion to use this thing? And I think the example that we used in that study was just a $10 bottle of wine, nothing special. For our folks, I had never passed up the opportunity to use it. And we said, when would you use it, when works? They said a Tuesday night after dinner, nothing special.
确实如此。我们甚至直接问人们，你知道，使用这个东西的正确场合是什么？我想我们在那项研究中使用的例子只是一瓶10美元的酒，没什么特别的。对于我们的人来说，我从未错过使用它的机会。我们说，你什么时候会用它，什么时候合适？他们说周二晚上晚饭后，没什么特别的。
For the folks that we had had them imagine that they passed it up once or twice, they did ratchet up that threshold. They said, maybe a Friday, maybe a date. And for the people that had imagined passing it up over and over and over, they were saying rehearsal dinner, 50th wedding anniversary, the moment I land my dream job. They were ratcheting up this threshold of something that was always a $10 bottle of wine, but in
对于那些我们让他们想象自己错过了一两次的人，他们确实提高了那个阈值。他们说，也许是周五，也许是约会。而对于那些想象自己一次又一次错过的人，他们说的是彩排晚宴、结婚50周年纪念日、我得到梦想工作的那一刻。他们正在提高这个东西的阈值，这本来只是一瓶10美元的酒，但在
their mind it had sort of been accruing and accruing and specialness to the point where, when is that perfect night? How many of us do see our 50th wedding anniversary? Now we're dreaming of an occasion that maybe most people don't even get to experience. Call this, if you will, the reverse marshmallow test. The challenge here is not in resisting temptation, but in having the ability to indulge in everyday pleasures. Another example from Jacqueline's life is a time she went on vacation and decided to bring home some spices as a souvenir. And it's not a very long story because I never used the spices.
他们的脑海中，它一直在积累特别感，以至于，那个完美的夜晚是什么时候？我们中有多少人能看到我们的结婚50周年纪念日？现在我们梦想着一个大多数人甚至可能无法体验的场合。如果可以的话，称之为“反向棉花糖测试”。这里的挑战不在于抵制诱惑，而在于是否有能力享受日常的快乐。杰奎琳生活中的另一个例子是她有一次去度假，决定带回一些香料作为纪念品。故事不长，因为我从来没用过那些香料。
I brought them with me from move to move. They were always there. They took up space in my cabinet, and it ultimately got to the point where I had to Google when do spices go bad. And to the point where those spices were almost definitely bad. And so they just sort of became a souvenir. They weren't really functioning as spices anymore. I wasn't really getting out of them,
我带着它们从一个住处搬到另一个住处。它们总是在那里。它们占据了我橱柜里的空间，最终到了我不得不谷歌搜索香料什么时候会变质的地步。那些香料几乎肯定已经坏了。所以它们只是变成了一种纪念品。它们不再真正作为香料发挥作用了。我并没有真正从中得到
what I should have been by putting them in my food and enjoying them with loved ones. What Jacqueline is saying, is it if some people have trouble with being impulsive, others have a problem with giving themselves permission to be indulgent. I think the typical way that we like to think of ourselves is almost as sort of impulse, laden, heat-ins. We see a candy barn, we can't stop ourselves from taking it or we have the
我应该得到的东西，那就是把它们放进食物里，和爱人一起享受。杰奎琳所说的是，如果有些人难以控制冲动，那么另一些人则难以给自己许可去放纵。我认为我们通常喜欢把自己看作是充满冲动的享乐主义者。我们看到糖果棒，就忍不住拿走，或者我们有
opportunity to play hooky from work and do something irresponsible and we just take it, we can't stop ourselves. So there's incredible work from a not-kinan and Ron Kivitz. They sort of challenge that assumption and think, well, maybe instead of being these sort of impulsive heat-ins, a lot of us are actually too controlled. A lot of us are too serious and afraid of indulging. So there's a lot of us that don't take any time off, let alone playing hooky from work, where we're so fixated on being virtuous and being good and staying true to our values and self-control that we actually don't indulge nearly as much as we should. Can you talk about one challenge with the specialness spiral, which is we want to wait for the perfect
机会从工作中溜走去做一些不负责任的事情，我们就做了，我们无法阻止自己。所以，阿纳特·基南和罗恩·基维茨的研究非常出色。他们挑战了那种假设，认为也许我们不是那种冲动的享乐主义者，我们中的许多人实际上太克制了。我们中的许多人太严肃，害怕放纵。所以我们中有很多人根本不休息，更不用说从工作中溜走，我们太专注于做一个有美德的人、做一个好人、坚持我们的价值观和自控力，以至于我们实际上并没有像我们应该的那样去放纵。你能谈谈特别螺旋的一个挑战吗，那就是我们想等待完美的
moment to use something, the bottle of wine, the expensive spices, but we don't quite know exactly when that moment's going to arrive. We tell ourselves, when that moment arrives, I'll know it. But in fact, at every given moment we say, is this the moment and we say, no, not quite. That's exactly what happens. So there's a lot of research on what's called sequential search, which is in contrast to simultaneous search. So simultaneous is when all the options are in front of you. You've got your five flavors of jam in front of you. You can see them all. And so you pick one. Sequential search on the other hand is if each jam was presented to you one by one. And so even though it's the same jams, the decision becomes a lot harder because you can only evaluate one at a time. And maybe you don't
时刻来使用某样东西，那瓶酒，昂贵的香料，但我们并不完全知道那个时刻什么时候会到来。我们告诉自己，当那个时刻到来时，我会知道的。但事实上，在每一个给定的时刻，我们都在说，这是那个时刻吗？然后我们说，不，还不是。确实如此。所以有很多关于所谓的“顺序搜索”的研究，这与“同时搜索”形成对比。同时搜索是指所有选项都在你面前。你有五种口味的果酱在你面前。你可以看到它们全部。所以你选一个。另一方面，顺序搜索是指如果每种果酱都是一个接一个地呈现给你。所以即使是同样的果酱，决定也变得困难得多，因为你一次只能评估一个。也许你不知道
know what's coming next. You probably can't go back and get one that you already passed on. You can't really evaluate all of your options at once. It's just not possible. And Jam is a mundane example, but there's really big meaty versions of this decision that we all deal with. Who do you marry? Who do you hire, you can really only evaluate one of these things at a time. And so what the research suggests is that when we're having options presented to us one at a time, it's hard to compare, right? You don't have all those jams in front of you. And so what a lot of us do is we come up with a reference point in our mind of, well, what would the best jam be? And that jam may not even exist.
接下来会发生什么。你可能无法回头去拿你已经放弃的那个。你无法真正一次性评估所有的选项。这根本不可能。果酱是一个平凡的例子，但我们都要处理这种决定的非常重大的版本。你和谁结婚？你雇佣谁？你真的只能一次评估其中一个。所以研究表明，当选项一个接一个地呈现给我们时，很难进行比较，对吧？你面前没有所有的果酱。所以我们很多人做的是，我们在脑海中想出一个参考点，即最好的果酱会是什么样的？而那种果酱甚至可能不存在。
We come up with this sort of idealized, aspirational, perfect match. And now we're comparing every option against that ideal. And so it becomes really hard to pull the trigger because we're comparing against this perfect, it's potentially unmeetable ideal. When we do pull the trigger, we may feel disappointed. We may pull the trigger much later than we ought to because we're stuck into this, you know, when I see the ideal person, I'll know or when I see the ideal job candidate, I'll feel it. And it creates a lot of complications in decision making that ultimately lead to not only poor quality decisions,
我们想出了一种理想化的、令人向往的完美匹配。现在我们正在用那个理想来衡量每一个选项。所以很难扣动扳机，因为我们是在与这个完美的、可能无法达到的理想进行比较。当我们确实扣动扳机时，我们可能会感到失望。我们扣动扳机的时间可能比我们应该做的要晚得多，因为我们陷入了这种“当我看到理想的人时，我会知道”或者“当我看到理想的求职者时，我会感觉到”的思维中。它在决策中造成了很多复杂性，最终导致不仅决策质量差，
but less happy people. So you're not necessarily saying that the ability to save for your retirement or the ability to exercise or eat the right diet or the ability to say, I'm going to quit smoking today even though it gives me pleasure today because in fact 20 years from now my health is going to be better. You're not necessarily saying those are bad things. You're not saying that deferring gratification is always a bad thing. You're just saying sometimes it can be a bad thing. That's exactly right. So I by no means is delaying gratification, a bad thing to do, and especially when it comes to pursuits that we're doing for our own health, and trying to make sure that we're
而且人们也不那么快乐。所以你并不是说为退休储蓄的能力，或者锻炼、饮食健康的能力，或者说“我今天戒烟，尽管它今天给我带来快乐，因为事实上20年后我的健康会更好”的能力是坏事。你并不是说延迟满足总是一件坏事。你只是说有时它可能是一件坏事。完全正确。所以延迟满足绝不是一件坏事，特别是在为了我们自己的健康而进行的追求时，并试图确保我们
setting ourselves up for success in the future financially or physically, that's all great stuff to be doing and things that I work on, and I think everybody should work on. My fear comes in where that becomes the only mode of behaving and at the cost of doing things in the moment for ourselves. We have to start to retrain ourselves to seek out things that make us happy, not necessarily negative things like smoking, but just a moment out in nature, journaling, having a really nice conversation, healthy things that are really just for us and not for our future self and not for
在未来经济上或身体上为成功做好准备，这些都是很棒的事情，也是我研究的内容，我认为每个人都应该努力去做。我的担忧在于，当这成为唯一的行为模式，并以牺牲当下为自己做的事情为代价时。我们必须开始重新训练自己去寻找那些让我们快乐的事情，不一定是像吸烟那样的负面事情，而只是在大自然中度过片刻、写日记、进行一次非常愉快的谈话，那些真正只为我们自己，而不是为了未来的自己，也不是为了
anybody else. Jacqueline Rifkin is a psychologist at Cornell University. Jacqueline, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. today on Hidden Brain. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Patrick Cherry at Apple.
任何其他人的健康事情。杰奎琳·里夫金是康奈尔大学的心理学家。杰奎琳，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。今天在《隐藏的大脑》。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是苹果公司的帕特里克·切里。
Patrick works on Apple's partnerships with podcasters and he played a central role in helping to launch our new podcast subscription Hidden Brain Plus. Thank you, Patrick, for keeping us moving through our 2-Doo lists so seamlessly. We really appreciate your help. If you haven't yet checked out Hidden Brain Plus, it's where you'll find even more of the ideas and insights that we feature on the show. You can try it for free and listen to our recent conversation
帕特里克负责苹果与播客的合作，他在帮助推出我们的新播客订阅《隐藏的大脑 Plus》方面发挥了核心作用。谢谢你，帕特里克，让我们如此顺利地完成我们的待办事项清单。我们非常感谢你的帮助。如果你还没有查看过《隐藏的大脑 Plus》，那里有更多我们在节目中呈现的想法和见解。你可以免费试用并收听我们最近的对话，
about how to find hope even during tough times. Find Hidden Brain Plus in the Apple Podcasts app or go to Apple.co slash Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
关于如何在困难时期找到希望。在苹果播客应用中找到《隐藏的大脑 Plus》或访问 Apple.co/HiddenBrain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。你。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。